[Music]
[Applause]
luna
the fastest easiest way to buy bitcoin
if you're just getting into crypto it's
the perfect place to start
[Music]
hey guys and welcome back to the lehigh
fans show
of course it's um powered by icon plus
capital they're a vc firm
so go check them out rose jose how you
doing
good to have you look you need to teach
me how to do that
i need to do one of those introductions
no that was beautiful
i need to learn how to do those fancy
transitions and
i like stream yard i do have an account
but i just don't know how to do that you
need to teach me
oh sure yeah no i made it myself so i
could take these
two um but before we jump in um i just
want to let everybody know that this
is sponsored by blockfy so blockfy are a
really
cool place to basically earn i think
it's up to eight point six percent
interest
on your stable coins that's insane
because right now the world is just
terrible
um everywhere is the negative interest
rates or flat interest rates so
yeah i definitely go check them out um
but for those i don't know jose
is um my guest today he's an absolute
online genius
um he's a business online coaching
genius
master of all trades so i just want to
please
his brains and basically um understand
how to grow a business in 2021 so jose
where are you based right now
i'm in dominican republic the land where
it's always summer
gosh i'm so jealous i was in dominican
republic actually just before
um just before covid kicked off um
in january 2009 twitter 2020 right
that's just
that's what happened right yep
know each other back then we didn't we
didn't but i was doing
bachata and i really got down with the
whole
dominican republic vibe can you do
bachata
i don't like bachata it's weird because
most dominicans love
bachata music but i just don't like it
i'm more of a rock guy so
um you know there's a big difference
between bachata and rock
so i'm not the right person to ask about
that type of music
no fair enough but i love i love
dominican republic um i was in punta
cana
um it's a great place but correct me if
i'm wrong
before you were online you before you
were you know building your business
online and everything
you couldn't speak english is that right
it was hard to speak english okay um
i was born in a family um
my dad is an immigrant he is from belize
and people in belize they
speak a weird english
when i listen to my dad talking with my
grandparents i don't understand because
it has like weird accent
but regardless of that he never spoke to
me or my brother in english
but but um he he had a job
here in dominican republic and um in a
school in a very good bilingual school
so i got a scholarship because he was a
teacher there
and i learned like the basics of english
but after that
i never used english i i only read it i
only watch
a couple of movies in english so reading
and listening english is not the same as
speaking it
it's not the same thing so i remember my
first couple of live sessions where i
was
talking in english and i was like
stumbling upon my words i couldn't find
a way
to convey my ideas in a way that was
persuasive
or entertaining or just
you know without long pauses or or weird
sounds with my boys with the with the
you know
the you knows the arms the um and the
long
long pauses so
since then that was 2018 when i started
like posting stuff in english and
trying to do my best speaking this
language i've come a long way
what do you what you're listening right
now it's not what you listen
what you would have listened three years
ago man
it's so embarrassing but the thing is
that oh
no matter where you start you'll suck at
first
and that's normal the difference between
people who succeed
online or in life are those who don't
mind embarrassing themselves a little
bit because at the end of the day
um if you don't risk embarrassment like
dude what are you doing with your life
are you
are you going to hide yourself under
your under your bed weeping
that it's too hard to get started or
people will laugh at you
of course people will laugh at you of
course people will make fun of you when
you're
when you're starting out because you're
doing it wrongly and that's okay because
you're a big
you're a starter so um it's not that i
did
not know english is that i did not
use english for 30 years
okay i'm 33 by the way i learned english
like
when i was like eight nine years old
and stopped learning it when i was like
12 so i spent four years learning
english when i was a kid
after that it's just reading and
watching movies but no speaking
until i was like 30 years old so it was
a long time between
actually using the skill learning the
skill and using it
and thankfully i did thankfully i did
because
look when i started out my online
business my online journey not business
it was not a business back then
what i did was um i started tweeting
i started using twitter to connect with
other people and try to make
money but i sucked at it like badly man
i made zero dollars for
for a long time for months um and what i
did was i wrote everything in spanish
okay and then i used google translate to
get the english
right because no really i did not write
good english but i'm a good writer in
spanish okay so i wrote everything in
spanish and then translated with google
translate and then tweeted
the stuff and people start loving
the tweets and retweeting the tweets but
they didn't know it was a translation
from spanish to
english it was a very dumb and stupid
and
beautiful process no no wait wait wait
let me let me use a little bit of
hyperbole to make this more
it's your podcast you go for it jose
gone so yeah it was
stupid but it worked and the reason i
tell you
about this stupidity of mine is because
when people start a business
when people are thinking about starting
a business or they have a business idea
for the online world or outside of it
like in real life
they might feel that their idea is
stupid or that's dumb
or that it might not work but let me
tell you
i'm the guy who used to translate his
exposed from spanish to english
using google translate and created a
multi-six figure business doing that
so if i can do that translate stuff
from spanish to english with a very
painful process of thinking in spanish
then translating it then trying to
figure out the best way to say it
because the translation was not perfect
and built a six-figure business with
that using the dumpster fire called
the dumpster fire social media called
twitter
what makes you think that your next
business idea regardless of how stupid
or dumb you feel it is
can't succeed let me give you another
example there's a
funny page i love it's called potato
parcel
what they do is they you know take the
potato they just take the potato
and they engrave your face on the potato
and the potato skin that's all they do
and they sell the freaking potato for 20
think about this a potato one one piece
of potato
twenty to thirty dollars and they right
now are a million dollar business
selling engraved potatoes with yours is
it good though is it good
is it like an actual business it's a
million dollar
business of course the potato spoils
because it's a real potato
but it's it's like a gag you know it's
like a like a
joke you send the potato to someone with
like what the hell is this potato doing
with my face on it so but does it look
like the person
yes they really they really they it's
not engraved they actually print your
face on the potato okay
so um they built a business with a dumb
idea
and they and they scaled it to a million
dollar business
so whatever the hell you're thinking
about um
right now for you to start a business
think about the potato parcel
uh brand or think about me the guy who
who used to translate his stuff from
english to spanish using google
translate to get the english
the english right and build a six-figure
multi-six figure business doing that
think about that what makes you think
you can't so
i always smile telling the story because
a lot of people approach me telling me
jose how do i start a business
how do i scale how what should i post
what should i do how do i get clients
how do i get started how do
i reach out to people and my answer to
them is always
um the following right now you're
focusing on problems that you don't
have what you need to do is ask yourself
the question that will solve an
immediate problem
and the immediate problem that you have
right now is when
well the question that solves the
immediate problem that you have right
now is when
do i need to get started and the answer
to that question is always
yesterday okay not now yesterday
the answer to that question is yesterday
so once you get started
you'll do it badly and give yourself
permission to do it badly
like you're new at something
even michael jordan when he started
shooting you know the ball
and and trying to dunk he sucked at it
and now he's michael jordan or think
about
um uh tiger woods when he started with
his golfing and stuff like that
i he he was not good at it and now he's
like the best in history
so when you're starting out give
yourself permission
to do it badly now when i say give
yourself permission to do it badly
it's not to do it as bad as you can is
that
do it knowing it will it won't be
perfect
okay because you're a beginner you're
starting out and what happens next
what happens next once you get started
which you should do
right now okay or after you stop
listening to our podcast
right um then you start you will start
getting more questions inside your head
and your mission is to this is to figure
out which of those questions
um we'll reserve when you answer one of
those questions will result
in an immediate return on your
investment you'll solve the problems
as they start appearing in front of your
face in front of your face
you don't solve problems that you still
don't have that's when you're starting
out okay
once you have two or three five years in
business it's better to have
a longer-term vision for your business
but when you're starting out is
day-to-day what problem do i have today
that i can solve today and that i can
see an immediate return
on the investment of the time and effort
i'm going to invest in trying to solve
that problem that will
bring me i don't know the best results
at the moment when you're starting out
this is the best approach
solve the problems as they start
appearing
i'm just going to jump in jose wait jose
i just going to jump in a sec
so several things going on here and i'm
reading the comments as well so i want
to make sure that we add as much value
as possible so if you guys do
have any comments um then definitely
just put them in because i'm reading
them as we chat
um but okay so really important you said
about being embarrassed i think that is
so key
um especially just from a personal
standpoint i just i just push things out
like
even even if i i look stupid or i seem
silly
um i also think there's there's
something kind of charming
um about making a fool of yourself um
just not because of course you don't
want to say anything stupid and you
don't be incorrect or
or whatever it is stupid i like
how do you say it stupid yeah yeah but i
just love the english accent like
stupid yeah same same as tuesday
and yeah tuesday yeah i love the memes
also
yeah it's funny um but you know a lot of
the time people do trial and error and
they're not sure what the best business
is okay i have a friend i was talking
about this with her the other day
she wants to grow online and and you
know build a business but
she doesn't know what her niche is and i
think a niche is often quite important
so
what if people are trying to figure out
what business should i do
you know i'm good at many different
things or i'm rubbish at many different
things
how can they really narrow it down
whether it be fitness
um motivation you know these are just
some of the
key things which people do online at the
moment so how do they actually
focus and pick something well
that's a great question and i will not
answer it
i'll answer a different question okay at
least you're honest about it that's fine
yeah let's let's let's let's make this a
little bit spicier
look um i am not
the type of person that will say someone
hey choose a niche
and then start your business no i'll say
start find clients get testimonials
and then you niche down now the real
question is
how do you actually do that how do you
get started
and how do you find clients when you're
new and then how you do
how do you choose a niche i i do it the
other way around
people say that riches are in the niches
and i agree with that
but after you start and you have a
couple of clients let me tell you how i
did it and how i teach my own students
on how to start their business so
instead of and also explain what you do
by the way explain what you do by the
way
oh okay so i at the moment i coach
people on how to monetize their skills
turn those skills into services or
coaching or information products
so they can make money online okay by
either selling information products to
their audiences if they have an audience
or selling their services so they can
you know start an agency or start
freelancing and
escape the nine to five job that they
have
or um people who already have some very
specific
set of skills and they want to teach
other people how to do that
through coaching i also teach people how
how to turn those skills into into
coaching so they can sell it to their
online audience or outside of that okay
so
when i take on a new student and they
want to
start a business and they want to get
clients and they want to niche down and
they want to
you know make money online and sell
their services what i do is tell them
look at the moment forget about the
niche because that's a problem that you
still don't
have okay you're the problem that you
have right now is
getting started and how do you get
started okay you already have
the skill let's say you are you are a
web designer
you can design websites okay now let's
grab that skill
and let's turn it into a service you get
paid a thousand two thousand five
thousand dollars depending on your skill
level okay
how do you do that we can talk about
that later on but
for the moment let me tell you like the
full picture once you once you turn that
skill
into a service or a coaching or product
then you set your eyes on the price
getting clients
the big question now how do i get my
first
client this is where most people just
start thinking about i need to
find a niche i need to research the
niche i need to understand what they
think i need to understand the problems
that they have
screw all of that you're starting out so
the pros dot what you need to do is
reach out to your family
and your friends and tell them hey
i just started a business i started a
web design agency
and i would love to design a website for
you
you don't have to pay me or we could
talk about a payment
so you don't feel bad about for abusing
our our relationship
let's hop on a call 10 minutes and let's
figure out a path
to create that website of yours so you
can start promoting yourself so
you can start posting your blog so you
can start you know just using the
the online tools that i will provide you
to make more money or whatever
okay you and i can assure you
you'll find a couple of your friends or
family members or acquaintances
that will need that service of yours in
this case
web design you don't have to charge
but if you want to charge charge at
least between 500 and a thousand dollars
because at the end of the day what you
want is the testimonial you want the
social proof
why do you want the social proof of the
testimonial well when people are in
doubt
we humans what we do is we take a look
around us
and we figure out what are other people
doing
oh they're hiring jose for web design
okay
i see their face i see that they say
good things about jose
let me give this jose guy a try they hop
on a call with jose jose says okay
here's what we're going to do xyrcy
pay me 500 pay me a thousand dollars pay
me five thousand dollars pay me whatever
you need to ask
for your services and then you get
another client
but at first focus on the people that
you know your acquaintances
your friends your family members because
here's the thing
you might fail that's a possibility
but you will yeah this is something that
happens
you you will fail eventually okay that's
just
a fact you're going to die fact you're
going to fail
eventually fact so it's
a little bit less heartbreaking to fail
when you're working with a family member
or or a
friend because they'll give you the
chance to redeem yourself but a client
they'll fire you right there so that's
why i always suggest start with five
family members and um acquaintances are
people that you trust
because then you can like in case of
failure
in case which i it's doubtful if you're
a responsible person
but in case of failure you can always
ask for an extra two or three days
to deliver on your promises and that's
okay it can happen it will happen
eventually so reduce the risk by working
with people that
you feel comfortable telling them hey
give me a couple of extra days i will
deliver your stuff and if i don't i'll
give you your money back that's okay and
i'll of course deliver the service
and it's a great way to get started and
make money and
um use that money to
if you want to invest the money that's
okay right buy bitcoin
or buy the what what do what do you call
it safe coins
i i have no safe no no we don't promote
safe moon on layers podcasts we just
promote bitcoin
oh okay okay okay but i i don't i don't
know anything about
that oh you don't we can talk about
safe moon or safe coin or safe whatever
i'm like
what is she talking about none of that
stuff is safe
no no no um but one of the things that i
think people often
um struggle with is procrastination
and motivation building habits and
things like that
um so before i ask the questions i want
to give
like a bit of background and a story so
i think
staying motivated can be hard and the
thing which keeps me motivated
is so simple it's literally survival
okay
so i look at it as like nobody is
is going to pay for me but me um like
there's there's no one it's
it's i've just got me in in this world
so you know if i want to
leave a country if i want to eat a nice
dinner if i want to go
buy a nice bottle of wine like seriously
i want to get that perfume
only i'm no one's paying for it but me
so i have to
work so and you and i really have to
work not just get like a basic job which
pays me like a
a low salary that's not gonna give me um
a lifestyle that i that i want
so the way i look at it is just damn i
need to survive you know if i want to
travel this world then that's what i got
to do
so what's your advice to people who
struggle staying motivated and then they
get
they fall down the whole procrastination
rabbit hole
if you if you are a man have a kid
get someone pregnant that will give you
the urgency the urgency of god to get
things done
joking aside um survival is a big one
survival is like a huge one and i like
for example how jordan peterson frames
it think about
the worst case scenario 10 years from
now
see yourself in the worst place that you
can never see yourself
and use that fear of that
eerie image that hell of an image
as a way to force yourself to get
things done because if you don't do
those things that you know you should be
doing
you'll end up in that hell hole and
believe me
it can be worse than what your
imagination
can take you if you can't
find motivation on that fear that's okay
find it in the positive figure out like
where you want to be if you're more like
that i'm more in the fear-based
side i prefer to scare my scare
myself shitless so i get
things done but not everyone respond to
fear okay
so what you do is think about where you
want to be in the next 10 years
you want to be in dominican republic in
punta cana surrounded by beautiful
latino and latino people with a great
body shredded
having you know the breeze in the in in
the in
cares in your face and the sun you know
shining shining upon you and and
toasting your your skin
and you become a beautiful um tanned
person and shredded person
imagine yourself like that and then find
a way to get there and that takes me to
what i told you about
a couple of moments ago when we began
the podcast
figure out the problem the immediate
problem that you have right now
figure out a solution to that problem
and then
find another problem that you can figure
out the solution at that same moment
and do that until the problems that you
have
are longer are the have long-term
consequences
and then figure out how to solve those
problems that have long-term
consequences
but at the moment figure out the
problems that you have
that have a short-term consequence
because you're starting out okay
um so i just told you about two ways to
motivate yourself you either
use fear by thinking about where you
beat in 10 years and the worst case
scenario that can happen in the next 10
years or
you can use a little bit of positivity
or positive
positive thinking to imagine yourself in
the place that you want to be
10 years from now two tactics that work
really well
and depending on who you are if you're
like me you can use fear
if you're like liar you can also use
fear
you know a fear of you know i don't fear
of not surviving okay
but if you're like not like me or like
you um
use positivity and use a better mental
image of
the future that you want to live in
i think that's the thing people get so
wrapped up in
thinking that they've got this huge path
ahead of them
and this huge gigantic journey and that
can be so overwhelming and it totally
stops you from starting
um but if you just literally take it
step
by step um and go with it do the small
things um i think that really helps
something which i always struggle with
um particularly
you know when you're working for
yourself is prices
raising prices this is so stressful
um so let's go back a bit how would you
how do you work out how to value the
price of something
if you're starting out always start
between 500 and a thousand dollars
don't complicate it really overthinking
pricing
when you're starting out is just too
much price between 500 and a thousand
dollars
that depends on the product obviously if
you're not if you're doing it here's a
service okay if it's a service or
coaching
500 to 1000 no matter the service no
matter the coaching
five hundred two thousand dollars
because you'll be selling your time okay
now if it's like digital products or
physical products it's a little bit
different okay
um price low and as you start getting
more testimonials
you raise the price that's that's a
process start with
50 raise the price when you get more
testimonials
then make it 75 then 100
then 150 then 500 then a thousand then
whatever you think and you can even
build a coaching around around that
information product which is
what i do you know i i let me tell you
how i
started with the with the coaching
business so i said to myself
how can i build a course how can i build
a digital product
how could i be create this video course
knowing that it will solve people pro
people's problems and not
waste my time creating it only to fail
to sell it
once it's done what i did was the
following
hey i just opened up five uh
spots for a coaching it's only 500 i
will show you how to do this this this
and that
i got five people to join because it's
only five hundred dollars
it's only five hundred dollars and i
coached them on how to
whatever in that time okay that was in
i got the five people to join my
coaching for 500
and i started building the information
product around the questions that they
had that they asked
me and um i got paid to build the
information product
and then i saw the information product
outside of the coaching so
i found a way to win
even if i failed what do i mean with
that
i got paid for the coaching and the
purpose was of course to coach but also
to build a product
that i could sell outside of that
coaching if the product would have not
sold well i still made the money from
the coaching that's what i mean when i
say
find a way to win even if you fail
okay i didn't fail i made a lot of money
with the coaching and the
and the information products but at
least i uh i got paid
basically to create the information
product this is the ultimate way
to create an information product man
you have the the people that will serve
as a guinea pig
let's say they will ask you questions
you'll answer those
questions and then you've record that
and add it to your
top you documented that you add it to a
powerpoint presentation and then you
record yourself
reading the powerpoint presentation and
then you sell that
evergreen process works perfectly and it
also helps you
make money while creating the
information product okay so
i want to talk a little bit about more
about that concept of
finding ways in which you can win
even if you fail i saw this concept from
scott adams he's uh
one of my favorite authors and when he
said that
years ago i think it was 2016 when i
started like
following him really deeply
i got i got that idea of actually
figuring out how i can win even if i
fail
and that's where i created something a
platform a membership
platform that i call sovereign
university
okay i started serving university in
um and i got a hundred members
in the first month they were paying me
between forty five dollars and
forty four dollars and fifty dollars a
month a hundred members
that's around five thousand dollars in
in monthly revenue
and let me tell you i failed because i
closed the university
okay but i also won
because i created so much content so
many courses for people inside
the sovereign university that i was able
to make
ten times that tens not ten times that
much more than ten times the money i
made with some university
for example from my time
when i had some university back then
which i reopened
la on monday by the way um i created a
course
the course is how to create websites
without coding
okay it was for members of summer
university back in 2019.
once i stopped like once i like oh man
some university this is too much for me
and i closed it i
sold the course the straight line web
design course
that course has made me over a hundred
thousand dollars
wow so i lost because i
failed because i had to close the
university but i had all that
information then i that then i monetized
outside of the university so i figured
out a way to win
even if i lost in your life think about
those situations where you think
you might fail because there's a it's
always a possibility but even if you
fail
you win for example learning skills
or skill learning any type of skill will
always produce some kind of good results
even if you fail to for example monetize
that skill
become famous doing whatever you're
doing with that skill
you will still have that skill let's say
that you want to learn how to write
and you want to sell the writing skill
we call that copywriting
like writing for persuading that's
copywriting
let's say that you fail to create a
agency around copywriting you get a
couple of clients but then
you're just making ten thousand dollars
a month and you say like oh it's too
much work for too
too little money what happens next you
still have the copywriting skill
you can teach other people that skill or
you can use that skill
for your own gains you can launch on a
newsletter
you get people to join your newsletter
and then you sell them stuff
in that newsletter it could be coaching
on how to copyright it could be coaching
on on how to start a business it could
be coaching it could be information
products
it could be whatever the hell you can
imagine you can sell with that skill
so you found skill that even if you
failed let's say monetizing that skill
you still
keep that skill and
then you start stacking more of these
skills that they add up
okay they add up and they help you
become more persuasive they help you
become
a more valuable individual they help you
become an individual that actually
provides more value to the world and
when you provide value to the world
a lot of great things start happening to
you let's say
yourself you provide a lot of free value
on your on your twitter account and
that's why you have a hundred thousand
followers
okay and you say oh i sometimes post
silly videos and you do and they're
funny
because they they are endearing you know
like you said
and you risk embarrassment and risk
embarrassment paid off massively
you now have a hundred thousand
followers liking your stuff
retweeting your stuff you now have
people paying you
paying you just to name them
on your podcast or i don't know if
they're paying you but they're giving
you something
no yeah your sponsors they give you
something it could be
fi some financial something financially
or
a privilege of early access to some
stuff but they give you something
in exchange for just opening your mouth
and saying
this pasca this podcast is sponsored by
jose rosado
and that's all you have to do why
because you risk embarrassment
and you did to put it you put in the
work and i bet when you started tweeting
it was weird right you felt a little bit
of comfortable
you said like what can people learn from
me
what can people find how can people find
interest in what i have to say i'm just
when you started out twitter you had
like
22 years when you were like how many 22
23.
oh i've been on twitter for years but i
i i wasn't trying
to grow i only started
march last year march last year and from
march
last year when you started taking it
seriously what happened
you grew yeah the worst case scenario is
that
what your account doesn't grow but still
you get some kind of
reward for posting about bitcoins and
about the things that you love
so you found a way to win even if you
lose
and when i say lose it's not getting the
followers but winning
looks like this you build a community
you reach out to famous people
you have access to other people on the
platform
you can communicate with them you can
send them a direct message
i saw you posting the other day that you
want to have elon musk on your
on your podcast and i believe you'll be
able to pull that one out
how i have no freaking idea but that
eventually will happen
yeah you put it out there in the world
the worst thing that can happen is that
elon musk doesn't come to your podcast
and meh you know like okay
i'll have jose rosa or i have whatever i
have
someone else okay so um
you put yourself in the in a place of of
risking embarrassment by saying i want
to have
ilan on my podcast elon come and you
tweet that
and you tweeted that it might work
it might not work so you found a way to
win
even if you lose you win because you had
the
uh the balls let's say the ovaries to
say
yes you could say chill yeah
yeah yeah
a a you had the guts to say elon i want
to
i want to um interview you i want to
have you as a guest on my podcast
he doesn't come nothing happens he comes
and you win
you win you get more famous liar goes
from 100 000 followers to 500 000
followers from day to night
from tonight today i don't know i don't
know how to say it yeah but um
that's what happens when you put
yourself out there and you stick your
neck out
risking that someone grasped a machete
and you know
cut your head it's true it's like they
say
um it's okay you breathe you breathe
i'll take it from i'll take it i'll take
this bit
it's it's like they say you know if you
don't ask you don't get
basically um and yeah no i mean i'm i'm
happy to embarrass myself to be honest
because at least i at least i have fun
and at least i
i make myself laugh that's all that
matters um
but you know we're talking about
building online businesses
as if it's so obvious that one should do
it right
um and i to some people it's not to me
it is
just given everything we've seen with
covert and everything like that but
in your words why would you say it's so
important to build
an online business or just to be able to
make money online
speed speed
okay speed because what's the difference
between an online business and
enough and offline business speed
the process is the same offline or
online
you need clients you need to find
clients
no matter if it's offline or online no
matter if it's online or offline
you need to find clients and with the
internet
it's so much faster to get started
because let me tell you let's say that
you want lya's your
um you want to create her website
let's say all you have to do is open
your twitter account
record yourself saying the following
words hey liam
i love how you how enthusiastic you are
with your tweets and with your videos
and i noticed that you know you could
actually start
let's say um leveraging that attention
that you get on twitter
and i notice that you don't have a
website i would love to create a website
for you
if this sounds like something that you
want for your business
reply to this message and i would love i
would love to have a quick
10 minute chat with you that's all you
have i have to say
i actually had somebody do that um a few
months ago
exactly like that and i'm gonna guess
from that message he's
um a client maybe a follower no client
that's right i'm gonna guess
maybe maybe who knows but that's it
that's all you have to do
it's so much faster that going to a door
knocking it and saying hey my name is
jose can i talk to the manager
no you have because you have the
secretary or some or
or somebody that would say no no no no
go away
he's busy or she's busy online
you find the owner on twitter you find
the owner on instagram you find the
owner on linkedin which is a great
platform to find the owners
and you send them a direct message
directly to them
offering your services okay and it's
less risky than and less frightening
than calling someone out of the blue
we call this called calling it's really
hard to call someone like hey
i have this for you do you want to buy
it
i hate that i it you know i'm not
someone that
gets embarrassed quickly or that has
that kind of personality that says like
oh
it's scary to do that but called calling
someone to me that's scariest really
oh i don't do it it scares me i i don't
i don't want to be rejected
with you know hearing it i don't but i
prefer to be rejected with a
with a word with just someone typing the
word no it feels less personal
so um there's a great thing about the
online world
speed i want to just jump in um because
another thing which i really want to
just talk about for a sec actually which
i had no plans for talking about but
let's just do it anyway is email okay
newsletters aside reaching out to
somebody via email is dead
right no see i totally need
newsletters yes but emails as if like
if i want to get you on my podcast i dm
you i don't i don't email you if i want
to do business with you i dm you i don't
email you
there's certain truth truth behind that
you know um it takes balls
to dm the owner of tesla you know no
i do think so yes yes the thing is that
you are courageous you are a courageous
woman okay but most people
are sk you don't think it but that's
what we see and that's what i see in you
you are a courageous woman you take
risks
you show your face you stick your neck
out and you risk people telling you
stop talking what the hell are you
talking about
someone said i'll just say someone said
on tick tock actually yesterday oh no
it's that bell end again and i was just
like
oh and that's like you know you
i can only imagine the the type of dms
that people send you
from you know dick pics and stuff like
that from
shut your mouth and the b word you know
you risk that kind of messages you know
so you are a courageous woman
you are a courageous individual and
people see that and
that's one of the main reasons also when
you have a hundred thousand followers
because you are risking embarrassment
and a lot of people don't have the
the courage to do that okay so
believe it believe it you are courageous
person
so um back to the topic email
is that um
dm is the king okay but emails
if you automate it is the universe it's
more than just that it's the creator
because you can automate that okay you
can automate to reach out
reaching out to people let's say that
you have
20 emails of people that you want to
invite to your podcast
very important people you can automate
that
you can totally automate that you put
the emails in the database
and you can send those 20 emails custom
tailored for that person
where you just in the first line you
talk a little bit about them but then
everything else
the invitation and the links it's like
copy paste
so all you have to do is the first line
of that email to get their attention
um you personalize it you custom tailor
for their for
for who they are so they know that you
did your research sorry
oh i hate when people do that yeah of
course you can but i would just
say when people do that okay the thing i
i forgot to ask you if i can curse
so so they know that you
conducted your research and that you
know who you are reaching to
okay and then it's just copy paste the
the
the rest of the thing and you can
automate that crap so instead of
spending
10 hours dming people one by one
you put that those 20
30 100 emails in the database you create
a custom meme
first line for these people to get their
attention everything else is copy paste
and here's the thing the follow-up can
also be
automated the follow-up is the hardest
part because it's the one that you'll
have to be like
hey bumping this up hey
i'm gonna know what you're doing you
can't just milk it yeah so you have to
follow up follow up follow up follow up
in your case how many times do you have
to follow up on our
on someone that you want to interview i
guess that's something you have to
follow up
five i don't do emails i just don't um
just on that point though most my photos
are in crypto so they'll know a guy
called bruce fenton
i've been trying to get bruce on i'm i
finally interviewed him but i've been
trying to act you're being courageous
right now
you're making that into reality you want
to interview him and you're saying it
right now that takes courage
no like we what i'm saying is like i did
interview him but i'd been
messaging only only like last month but
i've been messaging him since like 2018.
so it took me three years and um
i was like bruce it's me again you know
i just want to have a chat
um so yeah it's funny but
you can automate that with emails so you
don't have to be like
yeah so that's the thing if you're doing
it manually email it's really
uh it's just a lot of time
low return on investment but if you
automate it and there are a lot of
um software to do that you can give an
there's something also called i believe
g-mass
d-m-a-s-s let me see g-mass
where you can like just add a couple of
emails
custom add some like tags and stuff like
that to change the first name of the
person and stuff like that
and you can send a bunch of emails
custom tailored for the person
that integrates gmask integrates
perfectly with
gmail so it's it's really really really
powerful
you said g mass g-m-a-s-s
perfect mass massive okay yeah good so
um you automate that
and you don't have to be spending time
on hey i'm here it's me again
so that's one of the great things about
emails you can automate it but the dm
it's more personal and also i appreciate
them
yeah people appreciate the at least the
effort of
reaching out you know like it's very
personal because it's a direct message
to the person
and they see that they see the courage
of you just saying hey it's me again
and if you send a video it's even more
courageous which i
highly encourage people to send video
messages instead of just
text message because it takes a lot of
courage to record yourself hey lia i
want to create your website
if you're interested say yes and we can
have a quick chat
on on how to make that happen so if
you're
anyone who is listening right now here's
what i want you to do
once we stop this recording if you have
a service
and you feel that layer or me or some
i hope you i hope i pronounce your name
right i always call you liar
it's okay it's okay it's it's actually
leia
it's more of an a sound but i mean
you're english literally yeah i'm not
gonna yeah
no no you i'm like damn i i've been
thinking am i pronouncing this this
name correctly i'm you know i just
ripped and i i
risk embarrassment and now i just
embarrassed myself so um
back to the main topic go into people's
dms
record yourself um telling them that you
want to create something for them
it could be content it could be a
website it could be emails it could be
let's say the person needs a lawyer and
you're a lawyer send them a video
oh oh yeah look look leia
needs a lawyer so if you're a lawyer and
you're listening to this podcast
she needs a liar slide into her the abs
and send her a pitch i want to be your
lawyer
so it's not simple well it's not easy
but it's simple the process is simple
you let people know what you do and if
they have a problem that you can solve
they'll say
okay let's have a quick chat and once
you have them on the phone
you do your magic you tell them about
the benefits of working with you
you offer them a guarantee and you close
the deal on the phone
of course i'm simplifying the process
but
regardless if it's online business or
offline business
it works the same because at the end of
the day at the end of the day
what you want to build is connection
with people you want to build that
um sense of trust with the person
and you can do that online and offline
so
again the difference between offline and
online business is speed
online is just much more faster than
offline and of course it depends on the
business because there are some offline
businesses that
make a lot of money um
but um if you're more in the service
based
type of business online is just faster
because you have the emails you have the
direct messages you can automate all of
that
you can automate all of that and you can
just let the machine the computer do the
grunt work for you and you focus on
closing the deal on the phone because at
the end of the day you will have to have
a quick chat with that person
either on zoom or the phone or just a
phone call
usually soon because we now have been
forced to
you know to have some calls which i love
i love it i don't have to to go to other
people's
businesses to have a meeting i can just
send them a assume link
and that's it that's online business man
really if you're thinking about online
business like selling information
products it's a little bit different but
if you are a service based
business meaning a do it for you
business
i will do that for you use the online
resources and tools that you have at
your disposal emails
direct messages social media
linkedin is a special one to make money
twitter to talk about what you do
twitter is especially good to sell
services it's insanely powerful and
people just think it's for
politics or or for i don't know bitcoin
or whatever it's such
well you can make a lot of money with
bitcoin but a
it's so much more than politics bitcoin
and posting
so much more than that elon for example
i remember he posted
with a tweet he just posted about the
tesla
short pants i remember they sold out
like in a minute
from a tweet and of course he's elon you
know
he's he has that star power but he used
his online following
um to he leveraged his online following
to drive traffic to that uh to that
landing page to sell his
his short paths so if you're not using
the online tools you're missing out on
speed
on making things work out faster for you
i think the most um one of i mean
there's a lot of important stuff there
but what's really important i think what
really resonates with me
um is the idea of personalizing a
message
and not that up um
so something which i think actually jose
you and i actually spoke about this a
few months ago
um you sent me a dm and you were like um
women posting their l's
um but i think i think you missed the
point so basically well i get i get
messages sometimes
and the messages are um we need more
women
in crypto love what you're doing blah
blah blah let's work together
and i get frustrated when i receive
messages like that because i'm really
vocal about being
um sort of against that kind of identity
politics
um i'm not really interested in we need
more anything in anything
and i'm really vocal about it so when i
get people reaching out to me saying
yeah leia we need more women in and i'm
like that's an
outright like disrespect
because you're because you're you're
pretending that you follow me but you
don't
like you just you've literally just told
me that you're lying
because i think anybody that follows me
knows that i'm i i talk about us all the
time and
to me it's just an outright like i don't
follow you but i'm gonna lie and pretend
that i do
or i i don't know who you're like i
don't know who you are but i'm gonna
pretend i do know who you are basically
and that yeah
you could you can be honest you can just
say you can just say like i've literally
just found you
um and um i i really like what i've seen
so far blah blah like at least just be
honest about it
i hate it it's just it's the lying which
which just like really frustrates me
um so anyway you're really knowledgeable
about
all of this um but how did you become so
knowledgeable about it where did
all of this start because every time i
speak to you honestly i get
very stressed out i always feel there's
more i need to do
um eventually i'm gonna do a newsletter
but that's towards the end of the year
no i'm like oh god i stress you out i'm
failing so
let me let me redeem myself let me
redeem myself and let me
find a way to unstress you what is the
question
leia no it's no question it's
it's just a chitchat isn't it it's just
like
how do you not get overwhelmed you know
oh
that's no no actually that isn't even
the question that's not the question the
question
is how did you become so successful at
knowing about all of this
like how did you become so well read on
online business that's actually the
question
feeling overwhelmed it's normal
at the moment i'm overwhelmed with my i
relaunched sovereign university
and i can tell you i feel lost i feel
i'm scared shitless because i failed
once with sovereign university
and i relaunched it back in i relaunched
it
actually it was on friday for a very
specific for very specific people
and i really and then i relaunched it
for everyone on on monday
and i trust me it scares the sh out
of me
and i'm lost and i'm like struggling
to make it work better yesterday i had a
group session and there were like
20 30 people in in the in the zoom call
and there was a q a session and i was
struggling
like hell because i i found myself in
front of
30 people asking me questions and
i knew that the questions were so
different because of the different
levels of skill
and the business that they have that
i was answering people that had
questions for
you know more advanced users let's call
it like that and i watched having
newbies asking me newbie questions and i
felt like
the pressure of holy i got myself
into this mess now how the hell can i
get outside of this mess
so since yesterday i'm thinking like how
can i provide
value to people who are making more
money let's say ten thousand dollars a
month
and also provide value to people who are
making a little bit less than that
and now i'm trying to find an answer to
that i'm lost
but i won't let that screw my chances of
winning
you know um it's normal to feel
overwhelmed
and i'm stupid and dumb because i will
take a two
week vacation on saturday and i launched
on monday
but i said to myself it i don't launch
this
university i call it southern university
on monday
i will not launch this never i was
supposed to launch that
uh i was supposed to launch it in
january of 2021.
six months later i launched it okay so
as you can see i struggle a lot i fail a
lot i doubt myself from time to time
not always but from time to time i doubt
myself and right now i can tell you i'm
lost because it's not the same thing as
one-on-one coaching
this is a membership platform and i'm
new at
it and despite being new
the feedback has been overwhelmingly
positive
at the moment i don't think i've
received a negative one but once i get
it
i'll feel sad like it will crush me i'll
go
to a corner and cry myself to sleep nah
i'm just joking but
it will make me feel sad but
but i will find a way to take that
feedback
the negative feedback and turn it into a
positive
how by offering by finding the solution
okay
so even though i am perceived as an
expert on the things that i do
when i start something new it is really
overwhelming and hard and i'm the type
of
person that um when is anxious and
stress
gets tight here on the on
on this muscle right i've been
tied like my those muscles have been
tied for the last
six months because i i was
i'm still lost in regards to what to do
next with survey university i do have my
my plans i just haven't figured out
the step by step on how to go from this
side
to this side but once i figure it out
believe me i will sell something on how
to create a membership platform and be
rich with our membership platform so
this is why i tell you that if you find
ways to win even if you
fail you still won
so if for whatever reason i fail again
with sovereign university which i doubt
this time because i'm much more
experienced than
when i started a when i started and
closed it on 2018
i will still have the connection i i'm
building inside the platform i will
still have
the testimonials for the courses that i
have inside the platform i will still
have
um all of those resources that i'm
creating for these wonderful people that
decided
to trust me and even though i'm
lost i'm overwhelmed i'm stressed i
don't know what to do
they trusted me with their money
they trusted me with um asking me their
questions
and believing that i will provide them
the right answer
and i will win i will win
and i'll repeat that again i will win
and it's normal
to feel overwhelmed with a new business
or with a new endeavor
it's 100 normal because you are
new at that there's this guy david peril
i follow him on twitter hopefully he'll
follow me back one day
david peril he
calls himself the right i believe the
writing guy
um teaches people how to write online
okay and he talks about imposter
syndrome
yeah he's also himself the writing guy
dairy peril with double
l at the end um david underscore
perel or peril i don't know how to
pronounce it my english is bad
so um he talks about imposter syndrome
and he he he posted a short video on
imposter syndrome that
caught my attention and i internalized
what he said
he said when you are starting out you
are an imposter because you are not a
business owner
you are not the bitcoin expert you are
not
the ultimate authority in whatever you
are starting out at the moment
but you still did and in some way or
another you are an imposter
because you you know you don't have the
experience of running a business
but you cannot let that
imposter syndrome take a hold on you
you need to find the answers to the
questions that are bugging you at the
moment
so you can overcome that imposter
syndrome um
do you ever have that yet or still of
course all the time
still have that right of course i still
have that
of course i still well of course not
it's not obvious you know
but i do have that you the second reason
why i launched sovereign university on
monday
was because my wife told me stop being a
well
she didn't tell her she didn't say she
didn't say it like that like stop being
a i was
but she literally told me like dude
she's also part of the platform
she said jose what you have inside
sovereign university
i know i'm your wife and i love you but
you know that i will always tell you the
truth
i'm part of other membership platforms
and being part of your platform has
shown me
how much more advanced you are than the
other guys that i'm working with
so and i felt
like what do you mean with that okay she
told me first
the way you explain things it's easy and
she's
she's english is her her second language
but
my skill level is like 10 times hers so
she still
needs to work more on her english and
despite that
she's able to understand the the process
okay
first it's more organized secondly it's
easy to understand
and third i don't feel lost
following through your step-by-step
instructions
when i go to the other platforms that
i'm i'm in i see
a bunch of videos and a bunch of stuff
but i don't know what is the next step
and she told me like just launch the
thing
just launch it it's i always say this
almost on every podcast that i'm invited
find someone that trusts more in
your in you than what you trust in
yourself because that person
is the one that will like push you in a
good way
to become better and that person to me
is my wife and of course i
trust her more than she trusts yourself
herself
so it's like a you give me something and
i also give you something back
um my wife is actually the reason why i
started my online business
for i don't know a little over 10 years
she was always telling me jose start
your online business
start your online business and in my
head i was no
i'm just a i'm not a little
i'm not good at this
uh it and she was always
bugging the hell out of me start start
start start do it do it do it do it
you have it in you and
she is the top reason why i started the
online business
and the reason why i relaunched sorry
university
i found someone that trusted more in me
than what i trust in myself
and that's a big thing because i do
trust myself a lot but i still struggle
with imposter syndrome
yeah but as david peril said when we
start out
every single one of us is an imposter
because we're not the person
who knows how to run a business when
you're starting out of course you will
eventually become that person but then
you become the imposter
on the next level the next level
the million dollar or the 10 million
dollars or the hundred million dollars
okay i still have not reached the
1 million one million dollars in one
year but i want to reach that
so currently my posture syndrome is
telling me you're not a seven figure
a year person so what the hell are you
doing teaching people how to make six
figures
and i said to myself well i'm a multi
here's how i
lie to myself well i'm a multi-six
figure business owner so i can teach
people how to make
five figures or their first six figures
yeah so that's not a lie yeah yeah well
it makes
it's how i lie to myself okay i get it
to
to go to push myself forward yeah um and
there's no problem with doing that it's
like the fake until you make it
um i believe that just don't use it to
to scam people you need to you need to
do things
really good okay or at least try your
best
so um you overcome the feeling of
overwhelm by putting in the work
i'm overwhelmed right right now i'm
overwhelmed
but regardless of that um i have this
little thingy here in my arm you see it
this is what we call
a whoop app the whoop w-h-o-o-p
whoop tracks your sleep tracks
everything
okay despite of that
you will not be able to see it but
everything is green it's green
it means that i'm sleeping well and that
i'm doing well
in regards to how i feel and i can feel
it every time this thing is in green
i really know it's it's green because i
feel good
i feel it even before knowing it's green
when it's red i also feel it
even before watching the app so it's not
the app that's making me feel
bad or good so despite of the overwhelm
despite of the
of the sensation of being a little bit
lost
i sleep well why because i know
i'm doing my best to provide
value to people who trust me uh
with their money if you don't do your
best
you will not be able to sleep well at
night unless you're one of those
psychopaths that just want the money
but if you are a person that prides
pride
him or herself in being an honest honest
risk and responsible person
you need to do your best maybe your best
is someone else's
worst but that's okay with time
your best will be the best of the best
test
um and that's my my philosophy
at the moment i'm struggling yes but one
year from now when i have a thousand or
two thousand
members in the platform
i'll have a different challenge but i
won't feel the same
stress anxiety and impostor syndrome
that i'm feeling at the moment
overcome it push forward and eventually
you'll find a path
to win that's that's what i think about
that long rant right
yeah you're a talker but it's good
you're you've got a lot of conviction
and um despite being overwhelmed
you know exactly what you're doing
you've got you've got a path and
i think that's really important and you
know you spoke about the
the university and having that deadline
and if you don't have deadlines this is
something i learned from you actually um
because i'm in the middle of
creating something at the moment and i
didn't give myself a deadline
and it wasn't getting finished and now
i've given myself a deadline and i've
actually been able to
um it's basically done now so um no i
think i think everything you do is
absolutely brilliant um
i really love the philosophy the
imposter syndrome um
what that david perrault guy said that's
really interesting as well you'll have
to send me
because i couldn't find i couldn't find
it on my phone you have to send me links
i'll send it to you on
twitter yeah um that's really
interesting because you
you actually said something to me on on
twitter the other day you're like well
that's why you've got over 100 000
followers and i was like
yeah my head needs to catch up with that
you know i'm like i don't know why
you're still tweeting us
you would ask is you had a thousand
followers i'm tweeting as if i have like
1 000 followers
eventually that will get you into
trouble trust me i know
because when you find one of these
accounts that will
start talking about you and you
reply to them
and you reply to them in a very
emotional way
um it's not a big deal when you have a
thousand followers
but if you have a hundred thousand
followers it's different
because you're punching down and people
don't like when you punch down
or at least they a lot of people don't
like that
other people find it funny i find it
funny because i don't give a
puzzle a lot of people do give a so
it's something i've noticed from a lot
of
guys and girls that they grow their
online business their online
brand online once they reach to a
certain level
they forget that so many people are
watching them and reading their stuff
that they still act as if they had a
thousand followers and they punch down
and they talk about the other
smaller accounts so no i don't do that
anyway to be honest i think the only
thing that i
have to be careful of is i get a lot of
stupid responses
um so stupid i get stupid responses and
i just
oh you can do the valley the valley
accent oh i can totally do an american
accent like i can totally do that like
we could totally
we could have absolutely done this
podcast in an american accent that would
have been
awesome um i can totally do it anyway
that was anyway
i can't do it i have a good american
accent oh really
you just gotta talk everything
everything is up talk so everything's
gonna go like this and you gotta ask a
question after everything that you do
do um no it's not that good
girl accent it's funny it used to be
better
um but jose no it's been brilliant i
want to thank you so much
um it's been so interesting i always
love
hearing what you have to say um and you
know i find
your twitter so valuable so guys please
follow jose
his twitter is absolutely brilliant i'm
one of those people that
genuinely screenshots tweets that i need
to remember and jose is one of those
accounts
um like i said he he tweeted something
like um if you don't set a deadline you
won't get it done
and then i'm like oh my god i need to
set a deadline god so
value right there so thank you so much
you don't have to say what but when is
the deadline
speak it out make it a reality so it's
it's july
um end of july um 2021
2021 i just need to work out one thing
i don't know i need to work out one day
it has to be one day
what is the day put the deadline right
now
i'm challenging you it's a challenge
what's the deadline
say out to the world risk it okay the
the first month the last monday of july
would you say that the last monday of
july i'm not sure
monday of july let's put a day
that's the 26th of july
god i better write that down oh that's
very stressful
now you have to deliver i was going to
tell you that if you want to get
done
yeah if you have 100 000 followers tell
your followers i will launch
something big on a given date
that's how you add fire under your ass
so you actually find the urgency to get
it done and now you've done that
you've got yourself into a pickle and
you will deliver
you will deliver because you'll have a
deadline the 26th of july of 2021
miss leia will launch something
i don't know what but she will stress me
out jose that's what i mean
okay all right i'll deal with it i know
what i need to do and i also need like
um other people that i'm that i'm
working with to launch this to
hurry up so all right we'll get it done
um jose thank you so much guys thank you
so much
for um listening we've had some really
interesting comments so
i'd recommend checking out the youtube
jose afterwards just to have a look but
yeah people really enjoyed it
there's moon rocket ape who said this
was pretty solid honestly
so thanks moon rocket ape um and
jose manuel has also commented um so
yeah no it's been really great
um so also where can people find you
just before we end the podcast
they can find me at jose rosal on on
twitter
and on youtube too i believe um on
there's no ads on youtube
so just write jose rosale i'll be the
first one to appear on instagram it's
jose rosado r-o-s-a-d-o
h-q as high quality okay
um and uh my website rosa.orosa
dot d o which is my last name okay
rosado
rosa dot d o um that's all
that's how you can find me or when leia
retweets something
hit the follow button once you see me on
her timeline
there you go thank you so much everyone
we'll be back next week and jose of
course thank you again
bye bye always bye
[Applause]
[Music]